[Music]
Klaus fondo nanny Klaus Fonda Nani was a
minister in the governments of Billie
Brown and how much miss his father Hans
was a leader of the anti-nazi resistance
he himself doesn't shy away from voicing
criticism not even of his own party
we're talking to him about the future of
Germany and of Europe thanks for coming
it's a pleasure mr. fondue nonny you've
worked with some important chancellors
and your close friends with Angela
Merkel given your wealth of experience
does she ever ask you for advice no we
never discussed politics but politics
politics simpler in those days than it
is now in Angela Merkel's era is the
angle American manos debate is not a
defeat the world has become a lot more
complicated there are many more states
if you look at the US and other states
countries have a growing need to retreat
and focus on their own interests there
are signs of dissolution in Catalonia
the Basque Country and Scotland one
consequence of globalization is that a
number of regions are seeking autonomy
Brussels is too far away
Washington is too far away they would
rather be self governed and of course
that makes things harder when does not
the Abbott Nitesh really Merkel is seen
as the world's most powerful woman
some thing she doesn't like to hear
that's how she's seen and there's some
truth to it even so there is little she
can do to rein in Donald Trump and
Vladimir Putin how much room to maneuver
does she actually have there are two
aspects to what you've said the u.s. is
in so far problematic because of the
sanctions is always imposing
specifically in order to force States to
do things they don't want to do that's
their expressed goal the sanctions
relief does is blackmail basically yeah
yes and they can get away with it
because the US market is important for
German and international companies and
the u.s. can ISIL
anyone who doesn't do what it wants
Putin is different we should be spending
more time talking to him but the
Americans are in the way
blocking talks negotiations and any
opportunities to get along with him even
though good American politicians I know
and others who have a sound reputation
agree that keeping channels of
communication open is the only way
forward and Europe is weak why Europe is
weak because Europe can't agree on a
common foreign and defence policy I've
long been of the opinion that it boils
down to Germany and France Germany and
France need to take charge they need to
lead Europe there's never been a union
within a large region without hegemonic
partners and Germany and France need to
assume hegemonic status and step up as
the leading powers in Europe until
France has understood the opportunity it
has together with Germany Europe won't
make any progress but the opposite of
this is happening it feels as though
Europe is winding down
Britain is exiting Eastern European
countries are saying sure we'll take the
money but we don't want any
responsibilities the Italians are saying
there should be a parallel currency that
allows them to get out of debt can the
EU as we know it be salvaged
a negative no one understands what Italy
is on about let's wait and see Eastern
Europe is saying it wants to be heard in
this respect the u.s. is playing an
unfortunate role because it went out of
its way to convince these countries to
be terrified of Russia and it played a
not inconsiderable role in the Ukraine
problem we need to talk very clearly
about US interests and European
interests conflicting interests that's
just how it is refugees are not arriving
on American soil in adding ease whereas
they're here on our doorstep we need to
talk honestly about these issues but in
my opinion
and France are not speaking with one
voice and they're failing to get the
eu-27 states to speak with one voice
many countries struggle to speak with
one voice because it takes so long to
form government's not just here also in
Italy and in other countries too what
does this mean for European democracies
ad-libber and Democrat I would say that
liberal democracies not just in Europe
but in Australia New Zealand and Iceland
wherever you look have a big problem
there are no solid constitutional
structures that meet the needs of our
new era for example if you bear in mind
what happened in the Weimar Republic it
didn't fail because there were too few
Democrats in Germany that's what's often
said and it's utter nonsense
in 1928 Hitler had five 3% of the vote
support then grew during the economic
crisis when there was a sort of civil
war raging in Germany there was no
stable government we have to see if our
system for electing and forming a
government is sufficiently stable to
weather the turbulent times ahead and
they will be turbulent very turbulent
democracies are becoming weaker they
don't have to become weaker they could
just be organized differently if it
weren't for the constructive vote of
no-confidence and the 5% hurdle which
Italy doesn't have then we too would
have had 15 governments in 20 years like
the Italians democracies are becoming
weaker Europe's becoming weaker at the
same time social democracy is in
disarray
what's the reason in your opinion it's
an international problem and I'd say the
main reason is to do with some of the
problems that affect us all growing
inequality the need for a more just
distribution of wealth that's very hard
to achieve in a liberal democracy and no
one has yet managed to find a way that
works here in Germany we do quite well
when it comes to income disparity where
we are among the best performing
countries in the world but we still have
a problem when it comes to wealth
inequality well we
have problems deriving from earlier
crises by inflation after the first
world war and the devastation of the
Second World War we still haven't got to
grips with the consequences of these
crises that's a problem we're always
hearing these days about large
inheritances but many people don't have
one and that's something we need to
think about you've been a member of the
Social Democrats the SPD for over 60
years in the last federal election its
support fell to a record low of 20.5%
surveys show that right now it's at 17%
is the party now once again in a
coalition with Merkel shrinking it's not
because of the coalition it has to do
with the line up it shows and clearly
made a cardinal error with Martin shots
he was incapable of leading a party
leading the SPD incapable of thinking
through political decisions
he's a nice guy but he's not a good
politician he should never have been
made leader one idea to revive the
party's fortunes is to form a collective
left-wing movement made up of the SPD
the greens and the Left Party
politicians such as Rudolf Dressler from
the SPD are starting to agree saying the
time has come for a new type of
left-wing what do you think I think
something like that is possible but I
think we need to guard against the
possibility that radicals determine the
direction which is what often happens in
these cases in the past whenever Social
Democrats and communists have joined
forces it's been the communists who've
had the upper hand even when they were
initially a minority so we need to make
sure that we don't end up led by people
whose policies are bad for Germany for
inflation but you don't categorically
oppose the idea I don't think it's great
but I think it is possible that it will
happen
your hero Billy Brandt also referred to
a left-of-centre majority by him that's
the difference exactly
dominant ways I've studied in the US
where a manager at Ford and you've said
that the SPD still doesn't understand
the demands of a globe
life's world do you still believe that I
do the globalized world has made
competitiveness the most decisive factor
in how we behave for example trump has
cut corporate taxes we have a higher
corporate tax rate in Germany so then
Germany immediately wonders if it needs
to follow suit the competitive
conditions in the world you determine
agendas and that's a premise we need to
accept we can't keep saying that there
are no inherent factual constraints as
the SPD is always saying of course there
are and we need to deal with them
constructively when the SPD finally
acknowledges the link between
competition the market and freedom which
also obliges you to do certain things
which you might prefer to do differently
then it will get back on track unfunded
a little bit as we did Suze I already
mentioned that you're close friends with
Chancellor Angela Merkel and her husband
how come you're so close yeah we have a
similar way of thinking we're both
pragmatists we're interested in art and
music we meet up to go to concerts we
get along very well on that level we
take a very pragmatic view of the world
that's what you need to have if you want
to do politics if you're going to be in
politics then you need to face up to
reality and not champion hopes that are
bound to be disappointed when even in
torsion and often she also accompanied
you when your father was honored yeah 50
yes that's right
when Yad Vashem recognized my father's
efforts to save Jews during the
Holocaust I'm gonna Merkel and her
husband were there and that moved me
very deeply whereas my friends from the
SPD were not there at the time she was
part of the opposition that was 2003
then there was a very nice celebration
at the Bonhoeffer house
my grandparents house in Berlin very
your fan ties your father was executed
by the Nazi regime when you were 16 was
he able to pass on to you any important
meaningful life lesson by Laura to stand
up for what you believe in and not be
afraid when others disagree that's what
he taught me
mr. fondue nonny I'll give you three
sentences which I'd like you to complete
I won't stop stating uncomfortable
truths because stating uncomfortable
truths and being an outsider is the only
way to be creative yes B D will survive
because why I mean because ultimately
these days there are more social
democratic questions than answers the
answers need to be found Europe will
only survive if both in Germany and
France together take the lead and don't
heed what others say Klaus from The
Nanny thanks for talking to us